ん
ニュースは絶対眠らないとよく言いますうレポーターも絶対にないと言われますけども
でもまぁ
今日のトピックとしては日本の報道の言論の自由ということがテーマです
日本では22年間もすでにいます
体はまあ今日ここにいらっしゃる皆さんよりも随分長いこと日本に住んでいます
ではここで基本に立ち戻りたいと思います
時間の制約もありますしではジャーナリズムというのは何かと言いますと
ジャーナリズムというのは誰かが望んだものが印刷されたものですでも本当は
ジャーナリズム
ではありません例えばバーガーキングがすべてのバーガーは赤あるいは緑にしてる分
それに関しては会社は何か書きたいと振ったけどそれは本当はニュースじゃないですね
これは外国人記者クラブが報道の自由促進ショー
これを作ったんですけれども初めて記者クラブでこのような
ものをつくりましたというのは日本の報道の自由があまりに月にさらされていると思っ
たからこの余分な勝負を作りました
外国人記者クラブのことをご存じない方はそれはまああのちょっと年を大分私のような
記者のためのたまり場なんですけれども
でもそこで14
仕事もうしていますで日本の
へー新聞記者たちがなかなか話せないようなことを話せる場所です
ということでジャーナリズムというのは誰かが望んだ印刷物ではなく
それ以外のものは後方だというような状態ではありません本当は印刷をして欲しくない
ものを印刷物ですってこれはワシントンポストの元チーフエディターが言ったものです
ジョーシンオウいるもいったようなことです本当は
皆さんが望んだ印刷物っていうのはもう候補以外の何物でもありませんでは日本では
どんなものが印刷されているのでしょうか
例えば福島の原子力の事故
第一銀視力が
もう雄洋雄洋しましたけれども音するんですよ
これはあの地震が起きて直後から領有をしました
だけれども人にそれを知らせたくなかったと
なぜ知らせたかったかというと原子力はあのボケくるくてって原子力はこの飲んでは
存在が難しかったというようなことを知らせたくなかった
で例えばオリンピック委員会の
クールですよ長官は何回もヤクザと一緒に写真を撮られているような事実があります
ってクリーンがオリンピック委員会のゲームを開催したければそのようなことを隠さ
なければいけません例えば警察のための海外4数の1は外国人が大嫌いそして在特会に
属していてそう
してヤクザのグループから式人情を得ていたというようなことが色々あの探せば
たくさん
事例に枚挙がありません
なぜなんだ
エペルそうマンデラはかつてこういいました報道は国家の干渉から自由でなければなら
ない
報道は危険既得権益から十分に独立して恐れることなくおもねることなく大寒に物事を
希求していかなければなりません
でトーマスシフォンさんはこう言いました私たちの自由は報道言論の自由
次第であるそれに制限をかけ
京都すれば消失睡魔しまうと言ってます私たちが民主主義の番犬であると考えられます
私たちの力が失われれば民主主義というものも焼失してしまいかねません
で県月の長い歴史ですでこの長い権限すべき4に入るまでに少し
日本
を自由な報道の時代の話を話しましょう
雑誌そして新聞というのは情熱を持って書かれた時代がかつてありましたンってこれは
1925年に書かれた文章なんですけれども
この日本の報道は湯イギリスやアメリカよりも素晴らしいというようなときがあったと
いう事を書かれていますこれは大正時代のことですがそれ以降をすごく
非常に状況が悪くなりましたこの本というのは日本の谷の家にという題名です
ただあのいろいろ日付がありましていろいろな事故が起きましたけれどもこれについて
は全部覚えきれませんので言い切れませんですけれども
ポンポンでは a 例えば新聞 ekin フラれました例えばイオン方法が例えば
国家主義地域国会を a 棟たティ
例えば90%の人々がそれに対して反対をしているのに衆院を通過してもらうような
ことですしまうようなことです
でこれは共産主義を基本的には避けるために作った法案ですそして国の方では映像に
関する法律もできました
1930年代ね
地形が造られました nhk というのバーの布石が多い
マークによる独占放送期間であり何かが放送される前にすでに必ず金悦をされるという
ことですチェックし今ちょうど安倍首相の下で nhk が置かれているような立場
です
そしてその後は満州に関してさんかなりの報道がされました
0本
頭にあの戦争があれば支持率も上がりますので島人同首相の支持率は大変上がりました
そしてアン保護法というのはまあもう一回
修正をされましたってその時に
対象の前で話をしたときに人に対して一般の講習の感情を掻き立てるような国民感情を
害すような話をした時はそれに対しては罰則が科せられるということでしたバス送ると
いっても単位厳しいんをでいいショーのがいい
香木をされかねないというような方
率でした
例えば国に対してへ西洋の思想を持ってくるということはとてもあの禁止されること
でした
1941年すべての山 c 会社というのはあの発行前に政府に承認を得ないとそれを
はこうできませんでした
そしてライターの
中であのバルブラックリストに載ってしまった方がもたくさんいましたで私が当時働い
ていたらばリストの一番上に乗っていたかと思います
そして1945年春夏のころですがその頃はまあ神風の基地の話
そしてちょうど
守勢をする方々のインタビューをたくさん封じることがありました
1945年終戦を迎えました
nhk は
例えば園芸の桜荘始めましたかアンダージョイ魔法アカアシた a じぇじぇんぱーい
ましたね安倍首相にょじいさん岸信介
うわぁまあ戦犯だったんですけれども民主主義日本では返り咲きましたの
そして記者がそれを止められなかったという後悔もあります
そして2010年日本は版のポンプがーっ
方と後報道の世界ランキングで日本は11位でした
例えばスウェーデンのような国ですでも世界で11位だったのが2010年ですでも今
はその自由度である
行くとは日本では61位になっていますパキスタンと同レベルです
だ本当に日本というのは独裁主義者になってしまったのですか
どこまで落ちていくんでしょうかね御何故このように落ち方が激しいのでしょうかね1
つ2つ理由があります31一番人々のとても恐れさせました
日本の湯政府というのは
日本人がパニックをするかもしれないということでなかなかニュースを報道しません
でした
当時の首相の間なお父さんと話したんですけれども
例えばパッチン校
のいる
ということでどんどんどんどん8この魂が出続けるように原子力が爆発し続けるので
内科2分壊滅ではないかということで日本の方々が強がったということであまり報道し
なかったということでしたそして時が去っていきました
ということで加藤余裕がありました
でもそしてあの dpj 民主党の崩壊もありました
そして自民党がまた返り咲いて安倍首相が帰り付いたんですけれども
日本は安倍首相の副首相が憲法の変更について何か言った時にも猫心配をするべきでし
た
で彼が麻生副首相ですけれども彼があのな家の州憲法の話を持ち出したときに日本は
もっと何か考えるべきでしたっていうで私たちは考えなければいい
んですけどなぜ日本の報道の自由が崩壊したかったかということですけれども
例えば
小さな新聞小さなざーしシャーというのはゴシップに取って代わられてきています
そしてかなり後方を増えてきていますつまり何かある企業に対してを悪いことを書いて
しまうとそのスポンサーがなくなってしまうということです
例えば等
今日電力というのはこのエリアですごく大きな力を持っていますし
どの企業日本におけるどの企業においても高ほんの一行のモティングは東京電力です
掘っても遠く戦であればあるほど
技が広告をする必要なんてないですよね
打っても4石使うんであればその広告をする時に
プレイスが自分たちのことを好意的に応じてくれることを確認すればいいとそういう
ことになります
ブーブーで動くどんなことになってか来るかと言いますと秘密保護法のようなものが
できてきて君
辻交互聞くだけで投獄をされてしまう
それを政府が認めるというようなことが出てきます例えば
まあインドが意見し用具についていろいろしたりするかもしれないですそれについて
いろいろ勝てることがありますで私がそれを例えばそれが秘密事故を機密事項だったと
してそれをどんどん引き継げるとそれを南下与えたりもしなかったけれどもそれも続い
て
引きつければ5年の東国ありは更にひどくなれば10年の東北になるのかも知れません
で新聞初診部者は心配になってきてどんどん心配になってきて自分たちでは真実はもう
描けなくなってしまう怖がってしまってジャーナリズムはもはやゴシップに取って
代わるというような状況になってきますよね
どこでも買えばいい
えっを自民党が例えば政府に対してより良い好意的なことを書かないときこういった
報道機関は潰そうとはないかといったとき全部の新聞社というのは抗議をしましただ
けれども抗議に対してまた講義をする新聞社 more
いましたでこれはまあ一社は私がよく知っているちょっと古いにをろぅ氷の方々が運営
している会社でもう一つは名前の真ん中に系が入っている会社でした
そうでこれについて私たちは何ができるでしょうか
私たちはこの秘密保護法を無効にするということをしなければなりませんそして記者
クラブは一般に対して門戸を開くことをしなければいけません
そして例えば a npo の報道機関を作るということができるかと思います
アメリカで
はあるんですけれどもアメリカでは npo ということで近々だけで成り立ってい
ます広告に広告の収入に依存することはありません
でこれはあの50万ドルからできます
でいっそして最終的に
もう少し華水を続けさせてください
持っていこう一般的になかなか人の言葉を引用をするのは嫌なんですね
新聞社の人間ですので引用は嫌なんですが
でブラッドベリの言葉です
というのはジャーナリズムそして文章を書くことがなぜ今は大事かということを書いて
います
で
知らない人がいいたとしてそしてその人とちょっと10分ほど離していますその人の
ことを少しだけ分かっているかも知れません家族の人のこともシリグかもしれません
でもこの人が
何か大変なことをしようとした時にその人を止められるかどうかということは
知ることがなければ行動が出来ないという事で知らなければいけないということです
知るということはいいことです知らないこと又は知ることを拒否するということは悪い
ことです少なくても道徳観念がないということになります知らなければ人は行動でき
ないのですそして行動を私たちがしなければな